whether you're a group of 20 or like I
worked with the CEO a $1.5 billion
business last year your voice what you
say and how you say it has such a huge
impact but we're not exactly sure what
the impact is we know it's going to have
an impact so the most important thing
you have as a leader is feedback loops
it's like that Innovation right you're
always prototyping let me prototype what
I say and then let me quickly get the
data to say what the impact is and then
let me adjust that prototype like I
think prototyping has a real space in
leadership for people that really want
to evolve As
[Laughter]
[Music]
Leaders keate Steinberg welcome to my
show 20-minute leaders I'm so excited to
have you with us all today so thank you
very much for being here I'm excited to
be here too well talking for 20 minutes
about leadership and Innovation but in
the context of your background and the
the things in your experience that have
inspired you that's something I'm truly
excited about and I'm particularly
excited for this one because you have
extensive experience in bringing
leadership and innovation in the context
of sports on in international level I
believe having won more than 11 national
championships H in the context of
women's rugby that's right and the rugby
specifically is a sport that is dear to
my heart I've never played it myself but
I've been playing some minor role in the
development of the rugby ecosystem H
here in Israel and so I app great I
appreciate a lot of the fundamentals of
what it is to to be on a rugby team Pete
over to you tell me a little bit about
yourself and how leadership and
Innovation on a general but how does
that tie into your experience with
coaching in sports sure I mean I think
one of the so first of all Michael I'd
say that um Sports actually not a place
I like to go for an analogy for business
so that might be a weird way to start
this and the reason why um I don't
really like it is because the um because
our metrics are R so what we do is we
look at the score at the end and we say
winning team good team losing team bad
team when actually the winning team may
not be a good team they might just have
the best players they may not have even
played that well but they were just
better and the losing team could have
the better team because they maximize
their potential so I think we have a
rhetoric problem when it comes to sport
I actually think we have a rhetoric
problem leadership as well but I think
rugby is a little different and the
reason why rugby is a little bit
different is because of the way you have
to lead as a coach so in the 2017 World
Cup we were playing in the semi-finals
against New Zealand it was the first
time the US women had made the
semi-finals for 20 years very very
important
game and I'm up in the stats and so
therefore the players have to do
everything themselves they have to
understand and implement the strategy
they've got to decide on tactics they
have to deal with conflict they have to
do leadership they have to do they have
to problem solve they have to do all
these things on their own so I think in
rugby if you're a senior
leader you have to do all of those
things right if I'm the CEO of a company
I have to enable my team to run the
business it is not my job to run the
business so I think rugby in particular
because of it's such a player centered
Sport and the role of the coach is
actually a great analogy so therefore
the things I learned as a rugby coach on
how to empower my team how to create a
culture and how to help them come up
with new things I think is important and
then the second thing I'd say which was
really linked to Innovation and and you
know I was fortunate enough to have a
Consulting business and Coach rugby
together for 20 years so I took things
back and forth but when you're coaching
the US team in the Rugby World you do
not have many um uh uh advantages right
like you don't have as much money as the
traditional rugby countries you don't
have as many players your players aren't
as skilled and so for you to be able to
compete it forces you to be Innovative
you can't play the same game as England
you can't play the same game as New
Zealand what you have to do is you have
to find a way to play a game you have to
innovate and play the game differently
if you want to
compete I want to go back for a minute
to what you said in the beginning on on
the metrix question because you said
something that's that I think May raise
some ibrows and is not necessarily
intuitive the the winning team is not
necessarily the the the the better team
and and that obviously deems that we
have to trans to translate and Define
what is better so so what is a better
team for you so to me a great team is a
team that maximizes its potential right
that does everything it can to be as
good as it can be and I'll give you an
example in 2004 the Penn State women I
was coaching them we won our third
National Championship we were the best
team in the country in
2005 we lost to Stamford by 40 points
now to understand yeah for people that
don't understand rugby 40 like think
about it like it's a football score an
American football score 40 points is a
blowout so the the reigning National
Championships lost by 40 points and so
we came back from that competition and
we said all right we have to for us to
close that Gap we have to look at
everything that we do we have to like we
have to look at how we sellect we have
to look at how we train we have to look
at how we recruit we have to look at
everything and we did that and and and
we went into the playoffs and we were
like winning games close games pulling
things off at the end and Stanford was
beating everybody by 60 points everybody
like and and so we went into the final
no one expected us to have a chance and
we lost that game I think it was like
1714 Stanford scored with five minutes
to go so they
won but we absolutely maximiz we played
as good as we could be they they had a
woman called Jess Watkins who was just a
phenomenal rugby player she went on to
play for the US she's also an astronaut
so she's like a little bit like she has
a PHD in geology she's an like she's you
know an big over but an amazing woman an
amazing player she was just better than
everyone we had but we played the best
we could be we were as good as we
possibly and I could argue I think we
made Stanford not be as good like if
Stanford had played as good as they
could be then they would have be in as
easily but we made them not play as well
so on that game we were the better team
we maximized our potential and they
didn't even that we didn't win the game
and so when you're Translating that to
business outcomes you know for us it's
all about you know I'm the CEO of an
early stage company for us it's all
about kpi's Milestone success rates
right did you close the contract does
the AI does the AI model do what it's
supposed to do and the distinction from
the journey to the result is a complex
one for many young entrepreneurs to work
through now I know that you work with
many senior Executives but but with you
know when you're looking at it the
startup early stage ecosystem yep how
how do I react to this as a CEO myself
how do I balance these these ideas well
you said something that was really
important Michael was you said hey the
the journey from um sort of like action
to impact is really complex and in fact
what I would argue is that um
particularly in startups when you're
going into new areas you you it is you
are doing things that are unknown and
when you're doing things that are
unknown this is something that is really
important in Innovation is what you need
to do is you need to experiment right so
you can't have certainty that if I do a
b as if I if we do this then we're going
to sell more we think maybe like we
don't know right but we think if we do
this then that will make a little bit of
interest in our clients that our clients
will like like so that that un that
ambiguity of Action Impact means that if
you only focus on the impact if that's
the only metric you're having then
you're not actually rewarding the right
people and so I actually think and you
know I've done a little bit of work in
the startup world and um what I I
believe one of the reasons why
startups why you know the failure rate
in startups is so high is that we're so
focused on the impact and not focused on
the actions and if we can help CEOs have
better actions and really focus on them
developing their leadership because
startups have they will start with good
ideas they will start with very credible
opportunities for a business so why do
so many of them fail and I would say so
many of them fail because the leaders in
that startup are not focused on the
right actions and we're focused too much
on the now when you say the right
actions it sounds to me like you're
those actions are both the actions that
they take as Leaders but they're also
the the way in which the the
organization talks talk talks internally
behaves internally it's it's about the
the Rhythm that it works in right yeah I
mean I I mean think I'd say like s right
so we need to drive sales so what we do
is we H hire more salese well that's
probably a way to drive sales but if you
AR talking in your Marketplace the right
way hiring more sales people is not
going to you're not going to get the
return on investment right so the way
that you talk and if you're not linked
where your sales people are really
connected with the people that are doing
a technology right so the sales people
understand how to talk about the
technology then you're also not going to
be successful and if your leaders AR
rewarding people and recognizing people
in the right way you're still not going
to be successful so just hiring salese
is a piece of the solution we think but
there's so much more to it for a really
high performing organization and I think
that the challenge at startups is that
there's very little leadership
development right there's very little
like um developmental opportunities for
leaders to really think about even even
you know look you've got an organization
of five no problem you got an
organization of 25
you can still manage that you get to an
organization of 100 now there's
something called the dumbar number and
the Dumar number is some research that a
social Anthropologist did actually on
gorillas um and said look when um the
troops of gorillas get to about 150 they
split and doing some more research they
said yeah it's kind of the same once you
get to an organization more than 100 I
actually don't feel connected to
everyone I feel connected to a subgroup
and so move moving from your
organization from 20 to 100 to 300 in
your startup journey is really complex
but there's always no support in how you
actually need to be very different as a
leader when you have 200 people in your
organization than when you have 20 I
love that I mean actually I know we're
we're we're just about 20 people now in
my organization and I've I've been
working with a with a coach over the
last six months or so on my on my
leadership skills and it's been that's
great it's been jaw-dropping for me to
see the impact of first of all to
realize the impact of my actions and
then to realize that the me shifting my
my perspective and my communication and
my behavior the impact that has on on
the 20 people immediately is is pretty
yeah yeah and and it's really
interesting because you know whether
you're a group of 20 or like I work with
the CEO of like a 1.5 billion business
like last
year your voice what you say and how you
say it has such a huge impact but we're
not exactly sure what the impact is we
know it's going to have an impact so the
most important thing you have as a
leader is feedback loops it's like that
Innovation right you're almost
prototyping let me prototype what I say
and then let me quickly get the data to
say what the impact is and then let me
adjust that prototype like I think
prototyping has a real space in
leadership for people that really want
to evolve As Leaders absolutely what
what got you into rugby in the first
place well as you can probably tell from
my accent I'm not from the US right so
I'm originally from the UK and I grew up
and I played rugby in the UK I was a
relatively mediocre rugby player like
most of my friends are like you coached
at the Olympics like they grew up with
like you weren't that good at rugby but
my dad was American and so I thought
well I'm a pretty mediocre rugby player
my dad was um a uh was American America
has a pretty mediocre rugby team maybe I
can come to grad school in the US and
play for the US that was sort of my goal
and so I actually went to Penn State to
go to grad school to play rugby I
stepped on campus and I found out the
only undergraduates can play and the
reason why any undergraduates can play
is that is is college is where most
Americans pick up and develop the sport
and if you let grad students play your
teams would be filled with like
Australians and British and French and
South Africans and so I found myself at
the age of 23 not being able to play so
that's when I started to coach and I
became a much better Coach than I ever
was a um player and then here's here's
the interesting Michael this is like one
of these things so my the experiment in
my PhD program failed I would have to
start again I didn't want to do that I
dropped out of my PhD program it was in
geochemistry I went to the business
school got a job in the business school
in Executive Education sat in the back
of the classroom while professors from
around the world did short courses for
business Executives that was my business
education and then in 2001 start out my
own business to support my Rugby habit
because you can't go and spend four
months in at the Olympic Training Site
training for the Olympics with a normal
job and at that point had this very like
um serendipitous merge of like oh my
gosh this leadership work I've been
doing and this Elite rugby work I'm
doing is kind of the same thing and
forly in this like really unique space
of being able to take business Concepts
to Sport and to be a to bring Elite
Sports Concepts to business that that's
so cool I mean I think that that that's
just a all from the failure if my PhD
experiment had worked Michael I would
not be talking to you maybe you would
have been a geochemist right now and uh
no I would be a geochemist I'd probably
be a professor somewhere like unhappy
like you know I don't know if I'd be
unhappy but it's just funny like I look
at that and I've had such an amazing
professional career from that failure
that I had that it's like one of those
things I'd like to talk about because I
think people especially early in their
career don't like failure and I'm like
no no no no I learned and by the way so
much I took from my PhD program like I
read scientific journals about the work
that I do I you know I I I bring like a
knowledge of data and how to look at
data and graphs and things like that
there there were things that I took away
from that failure but if I had had that
failure I wouldn't be where I am today I
I love it when you so when you started
coaching and in University was that um
did you was that intuitive for you did
you was it sort of like oh this is you
know what what was the underlying
conditions that enabled you think to be
to to realize that you're a better Coach
than a player perhaps but it sound like
it came pretty intuitively for you so I
I you know when I started coaching I had
a lot of rugby knowledge but I didn't
actually I don't think I I understood
learning and change and so what what I
did was I took I took my scientific
background and I really dove into like
what does the science say about skill
development what does the science say
about
mindsets and what does the science say
about change and that really allowed me
to go on this journey to of continuous
Improvement and reflection I think I
think there's probably two things that
that like really help me be a good rby
coach one is um I don't have a huge ego
so it was never about me it was all
about the players and about the
experience and and then being able to do
what they did and then the second thing
is for whatever reason I love learning
and I love growth so I I was asked
recently on another podcast because I'm
doing a bunch of these for the book like
what makes you a good coach I'm like oh
I'm not a good coach now I'll be a good
coach tomorrow and yesterday I was a
terrible coach and so that continuous
growth and it's exactly the same the
best leaders I worked with are the
leaders just say that like leadership is
a journey not a destination I just want
to be better tomorrow than I am today
and as long as someone says that then
they're going to be a great leader so I
think that continuous Improvement growth
journey is the thing that really help me
become successful as a coach I love it
if there was one thing that you would
have to recommend
to Young CEOs of young companies so
let's take a um average of
28y old
CEO for a 20 person series a stage
startup
okay number one thing one one or two
things um probably
humility would be the number one um I
think one of the challenges you have
when you're um you know early stage
start up is that you you got that role
because you had some insight and some
expertise that is useful in the market
and um to be able to get the funding
that you need you need to position
yourself as this super smart super
insightful person so someone's going to
give you money right and and and so that
sort of like an outward view that you
have to have but when you come back into
your organization you need to have
humility which is I actually don't know
everything like like when you're talking
to to the VCS you kind of have to
position yourself as like I am I I know
everything give me I I'm going to
provide you with almost some
certainty right the the the funding that
you're going to give me is going to be
returned like everyone knows that isn't
true but you've got to at least present
that right I think that humility and
that openness to ambiguity is probably
the most important thing because
humility leads to both um insight and
learning it leads to Insight because
people will engage with you because
you're not the expert and they'll be
open to engage with you because you want
to learn and so and because people are
engaging with you you'll gain insight
and because you'll gain Insight you grow
and change as a leader and the reason
why that's important is that no no one
who's got a 20 person startup wants it
to be a 20 person startup they want to
be CEO when it's a thousand person
person
organization and and the problem that
you have is you have to go through so
many transitions on that Journey that if
you don't have humility and if you don't
have that learning focus and that
continuous change you're going to find
yourself kicked out because you're going
to still when it's 200 people you're
going to leave like it's 20 people when
it's a th000 you're going Le it like
it's 200 so I think that concept of
humility and openness to change and that
openness to being wrong like those sorts
of things I think are going to be really
critical as you go through the career of
your stuff I love it Peter I really want
to thank you for taking this time with
me and congratulations on the new book
coming out and and everything that
you've done and are continuing to do so
thank you for this really great and fun
conversation and uh and I hope that
everybody who tuned in also enjoyed it
as much as I did so thank you so much no
I I love the conversation Michel thank
you